[Música]
bien
i
[Música]
todos hemos escuchado hablar de esta
ballena posiblemente la única ballena en
la historia de la humanidad con nombre y
apellido pero tal vez lo que ustedes no
sepan es por qué se casaban tantas
ballenas en la época en que fue escrita
esta novela fue por la necesidad que
hemos tenido los humanos desde siempre
de tener un combustible en este caso
aceite para calentar y aceite para
iluminar las casas y las ciudades de esa
época
es interesante que el descubrimiento de
otro combustible fue el que salvó estos
cachalotes
ese combustible es el que usamos
actualmente en mayor cantidad
el petróleo ese combustible también
ayudó a que los bosques de norteamérica
y de europa no fueran completamente
devastados interesantemente el quemar
petróleo o el quemar bosques es
básicamente lo mismo y el petróleo en sí
es básicamente el bosque que vivió en el
planeta hace millones de años
químicamente hablando cuando quemamos
petróleo o quemamos bosques lo que
estamos haciendo es convertir un carbono
que está en forma sólida a un carbono
gaseoso ese carbono gaseoso luego sube a
la atmósfera y nos crea un problema de
contaminación concretamente lo que
conocemos actualmente como el
calentamiento global que a su vez nos
produce un cambio climático no natural
es decir un cambio climático
antropogénico o causado
por nosotros los hombres pero también
por ustedes las mujeres
nosotros los humanos realmente tenemos
mucha capacidad de adaptación esa
evolución que hemos tenido de estos
combustibles a lo largo de la historia
de la humanidad muestran que la
tecnología siempre ha estado allí para
ayudarnos y tantas veces hemos pensado
que esa tecnología nos va a poder sacar
de los problemas en los que nos metemos
estos cambios muchas veces requieren que
nos empujen que no que nos fuercen a eso
puede ser a través de las leyes a través
de los convenios como por ejemplo el
convenio de cambio climático que fue
firmado en parís en el año 2015 y en el
cual tuve el honor de representar a
guatemala en este convenio lo que
acordaron todos los países del mundo fue
el de dejar de usar petróleo para el año
o para finales de este siglo
desafortunadamente los convenios
internacionales no siempre son lo
suficientemente fuertes
hemos escuchado ya que eeuu el segundo
país más contaminante del mundo ha dicho
que se saldrá del convenio y brasil- la
segunda economía más grande del
continente también ha hablado en esas
líneas los dos países más contaminantes
de este continente entonces están
hablando de no seguir este acuerdo de ya
no usar petróleo
afortunadamente los jóvenes
han sido mucho más conscientes de lo que
está pasando en este mundo y apenas este
fin de semana pasado veíamos como en
todas partes del mundo desde australia
la india sudáfrica y muchas partes de
europa teníamos miles y miles de jóvenes
que estaban marchando y exigiendo que se
hiciera algo más por el cambio climático
uno de los demonios ambientales de moda
de hecho es interesante porque tiene
nombres diferentes dependiendo de donde
estemos ubicados en algunos países se
les llama cañitas en otros lados o potes
sorbetes o incluso pitillos aquí en
guatemala les llamamos vajillas y estas
páginas ustedes lo sabrán en los últimos
meses a través de redes sociales se ha
puesto tan de moda el hablar de que ya
no las hacemos es interesante ver ese
poder de las redes sociales para poder
convencernos de que dejemos de usar algo
que realmente nos ayuda pero que podemos
vivir sin ello y que ayuda a que el
ambiente no se contamine pero hay un
demonio más grande ese demonio es la
huella ambiental y esa huella ambiental
tiene que ver con esas emisiones de
carbono que ya hemos mencionado que
provienen tanto de quemar petróleo como
de quemar
bosques y otra vegetación adicionalmente
a esa huella de carbono también tenemos
nuestra huella hídrica la forma en que
usamos y contaminamos las aguas del
planeta pero también está la forma en
que usamos las cosas y luego las
desechamos
el problema es que esta huella hídrica
esta huella ambiental esta huella de
carbono cada vez está haciendo más
grande la ciencia nos dice que estamos
ya llegando o incluso sobrepasando
nuestros límites
mucho del problema es que está huella
ambiental no siempre se puede ver el co2
por ejemplo
estoy en este momento hablando con
ustedes exhalando co2 pero ustedes no
ven nada salir de mi boca el co2 es
invisible y a pesar de que está
contaminando el aire que nos rodea no lo
notamos el agua en los ríos de la ciudad
de guatemala por ejemplo va en los
barrancos los ríos de los barrancos
parecen desagües son realmente canales
de aguas negras pero como están al fondo
del barranco no lo vemos la basura viene
el camión se la lleva o nosotros mismos
vamos y la tiramos en el barranco y
pareciera desaparecer pero realmente no
desaparece realmente va a parar a
lugares como los que están acá en estas
fotos que es el basurero allá en
villanueva lo único que hacemos es
responderla bajo tierra al final de
cuentas entonces como dice el dicho
tienen guatemala ojos que no ven corazón
que no siente no vemos el impacto que
está causando nuestra actividad en el
planeta y por eso es que
tantas veces dejamos de actuar la
pregunta para todos nosotros entonces es
que tanto queremos hacer
queremos limitarnos simplemente a dejar
de usar estas pastillas o queremos hacer
mucho más incluso interesantemente
podemos pensar que hasta que nos muramos
vamos a seguir todavía impactando el
entorno ambiental y en ese momento
todavía podemos ser ecológicamente
conscientes acá vemos un cementerio en
eeuu pero no se confundan el cementerio
no es la parte sin árboles enfrente el
cementerio son los árboles que están
atrás una tendencia ahora es el de los
entierros verdes el de que nos entierren
en un casquete degradable que ayude a
que nuestro cuerpo al degradarse ayude a
la naturaleza a continuar este ciclo que
ha tenido por millones de años y es algo
que incluso nosotros hemos hecho con mi
familia
tuvimos una mascota que fue fiel con
nosotros por 13 años
y al morir nuestro perro bosco pues
decidimos enterrarlo allá enfrente en la
casa tenemos afortunadamente un área
verde y en esa área verde ahora nuestro
perro está ayudando a que la naturaleza
se regenere
pero no hablemos tanto de lo que no se
ve hablemos más de lo que podemos ver y
veamos qué es lo que ha pasado con
nuestros bosques por ejemplo en los
últimos 40 años cuando yo era niño
guatemala estaba cubierta dos terceras
partes por bosques pero ustedes están
viendo en esta animación que en un
periodo de 40 años hemos logrado cortar
prácticamente la mitad de los bosques
del país pasando de tener una cobertura
de dos tercios de nuestro territorio a
apenas un tercio en la actualidad esto
es en el pasado pero vámonos al futuro
que vemos en el futuro bueno estos mapas
nos están mostrando modelos de clima que
hemos desarrollado en mi universidad en
el lado izquierdo lo que tenemos es la
situación actual lo que se llama en
términos técnicos la línea base los
mapas nos muestran en colores donde
tenemos abundancia y donde tenemos
escasez de agua en el país el color azul
nos muestra la abundancia
y vemos que en la línea base una buena
proporción del país está en un color
azul y bastante intenso el color
amarillo nos muestra las áreas donde la
cantidad de agua es suficiente ni
demasiado ni muy poco y el café el café
es el que nos muestra esa área que
llamamos corredor seco esa área que para
nosotros es muy seca porque es más seca
de lo normal más seca de lo normal
porque estamos acostumbrados a una
abundancia del agua interesantemente ese
corredor seco el zacapa y chiquimula
cuando viene a ser visitado por europeos
que vienen a ver nuestro problema del
agua nos dicen pero dónde está ese
corredor seco porque lo comparan contra
ecosistemas muchísimo más secos con los
cuales ellos tienen que lidiar
pero lo más importante que quiero que
vean es el otro mapa en el otro lado de
la diapositiva ese mapa nos muestra el
modelo hacia el futuro y no un futuro
lejano un futuro de aquí a 30 años
espero que la mayoría de nosotros
logremos ver ese futuro todavía y en ese
futuro de acuerdo a los modelos de
cambio climático lo que vemos es que la
cantidad de agua por la lluvia va a
disminuir y la temperatura va a aumentar
lo que hace que la aridez de nuestro
plan de nuestro país vaya a ser mayor
pueden ver ustedes por ejemplo que el
color café se hace más grande aparece en
el norte del pp y aparece en la costa
sur y también se hace mucho más intenso
en la región de zacapa y chiquimula lo
que quiere decir que lo que ahora vemos
como un corredor seco realmente se va a
convertir en un semi desierto pero aún
en esta situación de tener una situación
más árida vamos a tener todavía bastante
color azul todavía tendremos
exceso de agua el problema entonces es
que a pesar de que tenemos ese exceso
siempre vamos a estar viendo y todavía
más aún en el futuro ese problema de
escasez pero porque tenemos esa
situación en la cual tenemos una
abundancia pero que no es obvia sino que
al contrario lo que estamos viendo es
una escasez en nuestro país bueno lo que
ocurre es que mucha de esa abundancia de
agua está con problemas de mala calidad
y por qué problemas de mala calidad
bueno yo les decía que tenemos la
costumbre la mala costumbre aquí en
guatemala de usar los barrancos como
basureros sin saber que en esos
barrancos en el fondo va un río que
recoge la basura y la lleva a otro río y
la lleva a un lago y finalmente la lleva
al mar esto incluso nos ha metido en
problemas con nuestros vecinos de al
lado
pero no solamente le echamos basuras a
nuestros ríos también le echamos aguas
negras y al final de cuentas todo esto
lo que hace es ensuciar nuestras aguas
superficiales
tenemos allí por ejemplo la situación de
atitlán que por tanto tiempo lo vimos
como un lago muy limpio
de hecho hablaba yo de que lo que no
vemos no lo sentimos pues resulta que
por muchos años yo trabajé en atitlán
haciendo análisis de calidad de agua
el laboratorio me mostraba que el agua
de atitlán ya estaba degradada y cuando
mostraba esos resultados a la gente
incluso me decía mire y no será que sus
lentes requieren de más graduación
porque no miraban el agua sucia miraban
un agua transparente no fue hasta años
después que yo dejé de trabajar en esa
área cuando por el surgimiento de esa
cianobacterias
el agua se puso verde y allí si todo el
mundo dijo tenemos un serio problema
aunque tengamos esa situación negativa
podemos todavía salvar nuestra agua en
guatemala al final de cuentas la
pregunta es
tenemos que hacer para reducir esa
huella ambiental
por un lado adaptarnos a esa escasez de
agua simplemente pensar en la línea de
almacenamiento tenemos 6 meses con tanta
agua que si guardamos alguna o mucha de
esa agua vamos a tener esa agua que
necesitamos en la época seca también
hablamos por ejemplo de dejar de usar
petróleo tenemos en el país suficientes
recursos renovables para sustituir ese
petróleo que está contaminando a la
atmósfera y finalmente tenemos que
lidiar con nuestra basura les contaba yo
que las redes sociales nos han ayudado
especialmente a los jóvenes a empezar a
ver estos males ambientales pues me dio
mucho gusto ver que muy recientemente
empezó esta nueva tendencia le están
llamando el traste no se estilan oído
pero básicamente es el de tener un reto
entre los jóvenes de juntarse y limpiar
la basura que tenemos en nuestros
barrancos
qué lindo sería por ejemplo que en la
época de independencia aquí en guatemala
vemos a nuestros jóvenes con tanta
energía llevando antorchas por todo el
país qué bonito sería que esa energía se
utilizara por ejemplo en limpiar nuestra
basura en los barrancos así que
básicamente tenemos dos opciones tenemos
la opción de pensar bueno vamos para
atrás un poco vivamos un poco como
vivían nuestros abuelos ya no páginas ya
no plásticos de un solo uso ya no abusar
de nuestros recursos tenemos la opción
incluso de decir ya no más petróleo y
eso es algo que nos urge pero otros
dirán bueno no vamos para adelante un
paso para adelante para adelante tenemos
la tecnología que nos puede ayudar cuál
es la solución para atrás o para
adelante realmente la solución son las
dos la combinación de ambos tenemos que
dejar de usar algunas cosas con las
cuales nos hemos acostumbrado a vivir
pero también tenemos que preguntarnos
si tenemos ya disponible la tecnología
para vivir de forma más sustentable
tenemos ya el conocimiento para saber
qué es lo que tenemos que hacer si si lo
tenemos y lo importante es que empecemos
a actuar inmediatamente gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]